signori miei allora erano un po che non
mi facevo male psicologicamente ma anche
fisicamente vale solo su super hexagon
che è un gioco che di base
se sei cattolico non c'è cominciamo
ragazzi io se riesco a fare una partita
di giro mi ricordo nulla e si vede tra
l'altro amico nulla ma so che di base
questo gioco a parte farti partire la
musica e dm nelle orecchie di rimuovere
questo triangolino in modo tale da
uscire dalle
dalle dalle pareti dei la cosa più
difficile che puoi fare questo gioco 61
you tube è parlare mentre giochi come
quello che faccio io normale e se premi
il tasto cerchio nel joystick mori a
prescindere questo magari era meglio se
me lo dicevano prima però tengono conto
del fatto che chi si può deteriorare la
mente mentre stai giocando e quindi
tasto per tipo da catena che tiri quando
sei negli hotel stai svendendo la doccia
uguale smetterla della serie basta lo
schiacci contrasto di bene e neppure
fatto e neppure questo non l'ho fatto
l'ho fatta arrivare a 34 secondi scusami
la gara e prova a stare un attimo zitto
lo so che è bello intrattenere se fai
youtuber ma è anche bello continuare ad
avere la sanità mentale quindi voglio
finire questo livello per cortesia
grazie della comprensione
[Musica]
ma c'è una fine ai ragazzi il fenomeno
però meno buono stiamo morendo
faccio quindi
l'orco demonio porco 60 56 croppi di
questi non farò mai quindi ma ma c'è un
limite o si va allin fini si va all
infinito
quindi io sono stava andando avanti per
la mia mentalità deviata quindi diamo
harder caracas e spinge non so neanche
se la musica copyright ata in tutto sto
casino spero di no perché
[Musica]
vai
marco del demonio era difficilissimo
questo triangolo ma questi sono pazzi
per il più difficile che che ho
attualmente che questo sporca trottola
porca
la vasca no ragazzi non si può fare se
sto video lo fa due milioni di
visualizzazioni in dieci minuti io non
porto non è giusto giovani sporca la
tutte non si può
no vabbè ma io non posso battere come
faccio a sbloccare gli altri livelli non
si può fare e va beh certo dai fate i
seri
va bene non si può fare niente
arriva almeno a 10 secondi vi prego
allora calmiamoci
[Musica]
ok
marco del demonio ho fatto come ha fatto
a fare 11 prima come ho fatto a fare 11
come ho fatto a fare 11 ecco perché in
questi anni non ho mai portarci a un
motivo orca vacca
no non si può fare ha fatto ritorno
indietro fatevi mettere questo quello
normale quello normale che in confronto
fa ridere
fatemi vedere piume riesco arrivare con
questo
porta la bacca morta ieri dopo morta ma
male ma male fortissimo
cioè io veramente non ci posso crescere
perché poi l'accumulo dipende da che
parte di giri se sei la parte lunga ciao
arriva è come quando si marin bloccato
nel traffico di milano uguale proviamo
all'altro che ho fatto 30 si riesca a
fare un po meglio di questo non è male
ci sono le persone mega esperte di super
ex non lo so perché spesa che è
diventato straconosciuto nel mentre
quindi so che ci sono persone fanno
miliardi di punti pd come niente il mio
però però considerando che satura ore 18
non è neanche malissimo ecco tre credo
poi ditemelo voi
ok ancora nei record quanto tempo
[Musica]
sì però dediche senso convinto che anche
giampiero che sta montando si è sorpreso
un attimo
vai
vai all
[Musica]
maronna lugano quando diventa tutto
bianco la mia anima trasceso l'inferno
non ho più capito niente però crede aver
sbloccato della roba per bene e venere
ardes test che il penultimo solo per
vedere solo per vedere come per
presentare l'ultimo devi fare un minuto
di questo tra l'altro non solo compie
solo per vedere come i ragazzi
[Musica]
va bene signori credo che la vita possa
finire effettivamente quale che credo
che più di questo io non posso poi non
lo so
[Musica]
cocido va bene neanche malaccio sai
neanche malaccio previse piaciuto
ragazzi come mi piace ditemi se avete
dei vostri ex super hexagon che magari
mi rileggo perché sono curioso sto punto
consiglio della classifica fatemi sapere
nei commenti ragazzo veramente curioso e
noi come sempre ci vediamo ad un
prossimo magari ti tranquillo e video
beh ragazzi
[Musica]